what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder i'm your host warren and
i just watched doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness now this was a
movie
that i had been waiting for for a very
long time much like all of you of course
all of the rumors going around and all
the tv spots showing the illuminati and
i gotta say
i love this movie
i uh there's a lot of really great
things to this movie
everything i saw in the movie i loved
right i will get into some things that i
wish were
maybe not different but like added on
because again i loved everything i saw
and this is a spoiler-free review
i won't be giving any spoilers away in
this video so have no fear that's going
to come out in a couple of days uh the
spoiler review so be on the lookout for
that um
this movie is a sam raimi movie i think
sam raimi was the
the perfect director for what this movie
wanted to be and i think it was exactly
what sam raimi wanted it to be
there i mean you can tell like if you
know sam raimi's work you can see it all
over this movie and of course he
directed it right but i think marvel
really let him do some things that you
know he wanted to do i think they just
let him
make the movie and of course kevin feige
chimed in probably here and there said
you know here's what you got to do is
what you're going to do because as you
know cameos um
so cool like
the cameos are so cool and no spoilers
but i mean you've been teased with the
illuminati and you know the trailer the
official trailer for doctor strange that
was
you know that was big tease um
and i have to say
the illuminati scenes are
kind of worth the whole movie
but not because the other parts are
actually pretty amazing
the
like from the very beginning the movie
is just goes goes goes and goes
there are some parts where it slows down
a bit but for the most part this movie
is just like like it's going and it
kicks off
with just fast it it they don't waste
any time with this movie which is
actually something i really loved
they just kind of get into it they get
into
doctor strange scarlet witch wanda right
the differ there's a really cool part
where they talk about there's there's
wanda there's a scarlet witch and
there's a really cool line from
elizabeth olsen
that you'll hear and you'll
automatically know what it is because
you're gonna go ho ho just like i did i
was like oh that's one of the coolest
lines i've ever heard and it's so simple
but um
yeah i think from the beginning
they really hit the nail on the head
with everything they wanted to do and it
just kept going and going and going and
the scenes that we saw like visually
this movie is fantastic like there's
just so many cool things
to see like really now
let's talk about the horror
speaking of sam raimi right um and
speaking what this movie was originally
supposed to be right because you know
the original director was supposed to be
scott derrickson who directed the first
dr strange film
and uh
we're not 100 sure but you know the
rumor was that the reason he you know
part of ways was because of the creative
differences that didn't allow him to
really go full horror but oh my gosh
this movie has some gruesome parts in it
and like a lot of creepy parts to it too
like
and i'm not a horror fan like i don't
watch horror movies but this was really
cool and made me cringe not in like a
bad way but like ugh like oh my god like
it really like there's some parts where
you're just like oh
like
you're really they just like hits you
and you're like oh my gosh like that
just happened
in a marvel like
um
they definitely
did a really good job of doing that in a
pg-13 movie
i i was
pleasantly surprised with how that was
because again i'm not horror for him
but when you're dealing with a witch and
sorcery and the occult like you have to
i think you have to really do that
and it was executed
very very well
executed extremely well now
i will say
the movie is actually not hard to
understand um i had heard a long time
ago that like the first test showings of
doctor strange and multiverse madness
weren't so good that a lot of people
were confused and maybe the movie was
supposed to be three hours long
originally and cut it back to what it is
now just a little over two hours but
it's not hard to understand they
they kind of
explain it very well in a very
simplistic way that makes sense
and
also spider-man knowing home helps as
well um
but it's not hard to understand it's
pretty simple which i think really adds
to the movie i think it was too
complicated
like i think a lot of us thought it
might be going in it would have just
kind of taken away from it um
but since it was so simplistic it
allowed the movie just to
to go like just to be what it is
to
roll on and just go from story to story
story and it's awesome like it's really
awesome like the movie is fantastic it's
i i said this a few times tonight it's a
cool movie
like the idea of it and everything you
see on screen is cool
like it really is like that's how i
would describe it like it's so cool to
see
the action in the movie
is really really good especially
the illuminati scene
that's really cool um
it's it's really really cool
and then the ending there's some really
cool parts in the ending that you're
just like
wow like
this is creepy
but it's also really really really
awesome and it kicks off right away with
some great action and like i said it
kind of rolls through
and just kind of keeps going
now
all the characters are amazing
it's very much a doctor strange movie um
because there's a lot of you know
deep diving into how he feels and stuff
uh but at the same time yeah the scarlet
witch is you know
main character as well right but uh i
have to say so she gomez who is kind of
a friend of mine
um
her she did an amazing job she really
did and i really really really liked
american chapters in the movie and this
is gonna lead me into kind of like my
two cents on what i would have rather
had be different
and i would say that i wish the movie
was longer
it could have been longer
to have more slower moments like i say
it's like punch punch punch like it just
goes and it goes and it kind of slows
down at some parts but for the most part
this movie is like it just goes and goes
and goes and i love that about the movie
like i said i wouldn't change anything i
saw but i would add some slower moments
because there are some like really like
scenes that are kind of touching between
like dr strange and america chavez and
christine palmer and i feel like they
could have added more to that to make it
like a more wholesome heartfelt moment
the same with like wanda um there's like
a lot of great moments with you know
she wants to get her kids back they
could have slowed down a few moments as
well
that's kind of
you know
my only complaint about that and then i
could have actually had more multiverse
this movie is very much madness but uh
not as much multiverse hopping as i
thought there would be
but
it doesn't necessarily take away from
the movie but it makes me go well i
wonder what we could have saw if we saw
more multiverse and i get it like you
don't want to make it too confusing and
again they did a very good job at
keeping it pretty simplistic so
i don't know if that would have been
better or worse but in my mind i'm like
i could have had more multiverse jumping
there could have been more multiverse
scenes and i could have had more cameos
but the cameos oh god
so good like
the whole audience was just screaming
when we saw some of them so uh i think a
lot of fans are gonna be
really really excited and uh
the fight is all the fighting and the
entire movie all the fight scenes are
pretty crazy good so
that's my initial reaction an initial
spoiler free review to dr strange the
multiverse of madness uh the red carpet
premiere was awesome it was a lot of fun
i was like this far away from
elizabeth olsen and she is just
absolutely
beautiful and uh
she's awesome as the scarlet witch she
is the scarlet witch so it's an amazing
night again i want to thank all of you
for supporting me this whole entire time
to get me here to where i can go to
these premieres and i'm tight with
disney and marvel studios uh so i'm
gonna get better from here so
i can't wait to see what everybody
thinks of this movie um i can't wait
till thursday where i can talk and do a
spoiler review and get
y'all's thoughts on what you really
think of the movie because i'm really
excited for everyone to see it i'm not
going to rate it until i do my spoiler
talk because i don't want anybody to go
in with any type of expectations
based on what i might rate a movie but
let me know how excited you are for it
in the comments down below and of course
i'll catch you next time as always woof